Le prochain du podcast, das Podcast UFO, avec Florian Will et Christophe Tietze, commence maintenant. Bonjour, bonjour, es ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein Hier ist unsere konfrontative Polit-Talkshow, in der wir die ganzen Themen wirklich hart anpacken. Ich war bei Investigativ-Ermittler. Auch, auch. Sie haben mir ermittelt, Sie haben mir ermittelt, gegen das Gesundheitssystem. Wo liegt der Frosch begraben? Der liegt, da liegen nicht, das sage ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich, von Kollege zu Kollege, da liegen mehrere Frösche begraben. Tausende. Wie viele genau, wie viele genau, wie viele genau, wie viele genau. Ich werde sie nicht eher aus diesem, ich werde sie nicht eher, sie gehen nicht zum Buffet, bevor sie mir nicht sagen, wie viele Frösche genau begraben liegen. Wie viele Hunde liegen im Pfeffer? Punkt eins. Wie viele Hunde liegen im Pfeffer? Wie viele Frösche sind unter welchen Teppichen? Und wie viele Gänse sind ein Rudel? Wir machen gleich weiter nach der Werbung. Wie viele Gänse? Was sagt man zu Gänse? Geschwader. Geschwader. Geschwader, Horde. Bataillon. Eine Lawine. Ich glaube, man sagt eine Lawine Gänse? Was sagt man zu Gänse? Geschwader, Geschwader, Horde, eine Lawine, ich glaube man sagt eine Lawine Gänse, sowas in der Richtung. Ich wäre gern der Typ, der sich genau diese Wörter ausdenkt, der so eine ganze, der einfach morgens Morgan, Morgan, Morgan mit so einer Kaffeekanne irgendwie, hat so eine Thermoskanne Kaffee, geht so rein in seinen kleinen Cubicle und dann so Morgan, Morgan, wir sammeln noch gerade für Brigitte, die
hört ja jetzt auf und da sammeln
wir noch, ja, wie viel geben
denn die anderen, ja, so fünf Euro, ja,
komm, ich hab einen Zehner, so, zack,
dann setzt er sich an den Rechner,
blub,
Betriebssystem
fährt hoch und
dann einfach so eine lange Liste an Tieren
und in der Ex-Tabelle spielt Spielt alles übrigens im Star Wars. Das habe ich. Passwort. Genau, ist alles ein Teil von Jabba the Huts Imperium, der hat ja auch eine Bürokratie, ist ja klar, der hat ja auch ein Büro angehängt. Nee, ein Kartell. Das ruht ein Kartell. Der hat ein Kartell, der hat ein Konglomerat, technisch gesehen, juristisch präzise. Die UG, eine Holding. Sein Geld liegt, das Vermögen Jabbers
liegt in einer Holding.
Also, George Lucas war ja
recht nah da dran,
im ersten Film so eine
Politikabhandlung zu schauen.
In App 1, ja. Hätte auch gut sein können,
dass er so Steuerrecht oder so Finanz
Unternehmensrecht
so landet in Teil zwei.
Es gibt einen Whistleblower, es ist der kleine Typ, der immer so und der ist dann so und der ist dann auch hinter seiner Schattenmann und dann steht nur so, ja, die ganzen Finanzen sind natürlich in den Seychellen ausgelagert, das ist alles über Briefkastenfilme, über Coruscant. Und dann sieht man Obi-Wan in so einem kleinen Hologramm, wie er in so einem Regen steht und sagt, das ganze Vermögen Jabbers ist in einer Holding, in einer Holding. Dann sieht man das Gegengewicht, dann sieht man ihn dann irgendwie im Raumschiff, ist er so drin und man hört den Jedi-Rad sitzt um und Meister Yoda streicht sich durch sein Gesicht und man sieht diesen kleinen Obi-Wan, der Holding, hochmoderne Technologie, die durch Regen einfach auch beeinträchtigt wird, weil es leider immer regnet auf Camino. Ja, das fand ich gut. Das fand ich richtig gut. Ich mochte das alles. Ich mag es auch aktuell. Wir beiden Nerds, ne? Wir reden drei Minuten und sind wieder bei Star Wars. Wir kriegen auch die Magic-Mappe nicht voll, ne? Also wirklich, fühlt sich ja gerade aktuell fast ein bisschen so an wie Camino, so viel wie es regnet. Ich versuche es wieder ein bisschen mit einem Angelhaken zurückzuziehen. Immer wenn wir in Hamburg aufnehmen, das erkennt ihr daran, dass wir erstens in meinem Raum aufnehmen, zweitens meine Haare nass sind, weil ich bin mir durch den Regen hergewackelt und hier gibt es ja diesen ganz feinen Sprühregen. Aber es gibt ja bei Regen immer so eine Kurve, ne? Du siehst cooler aus, du siehst cooler aus, du siehst richtig cool aus und es kippt, du siehst aus wie ein kompletter Vollidiot, der einfach
nicht rechtzeitig verstanden hat,
wie ein Ringschirm funktioniert. Ja, bei mir ist keine Kurve,
bei mir ist ein linearer Abfall.
Achso, du siehst cool aus am trockensten,
je trockener, desto cooler und mit jedem kleinen
Körnchen. Ich habe mal gesagt,
und da werde ich immer noch zitiert im Freundeskreis,
ich bin nass, eine vier.
Okay. Oder eine drei. Ich bin nass,
eine drei. Okay, da sind wir aber
unten angekommen, das heißt, ganz unten bist du
eine drei. Das heißt, das Schlechte
Das war es für mich. Ich bin nass, eine vier. Okay. Ich bin nass, eine drei. Okay, da sind wir aber unten angekommen. Das heißt, ganz unten bist du eine drei. Das heißt, das schlechteste Worst-Case-Szenario ist für dich eine vier. Ich sage nicht, dass ich nass ganz, ganz schleiße aussehe. Was bist du denn gerade? Ich bin nass, eine drei. Was bist du jetzt gerade? Jetzt gerade eine fünf. Ach, Stefan. Doch, ich bin nass. Oh, Stefan, ich bin doch nass. Also, nee, da wird es wirklich albern. Das ist so offensichtlich Fishing for Compliments, dass ich dir wirklich auch das Kompliment für gutes Fishing for Compliments verwehre. Kriegst du das? Ich möchte das ja selber nicht. Du hast mich gefragt, wie siehst du dich denn selber? Jede Antwort ist Fishing for Compliments. Du hast die Zahlen reingeführt. Ich versuche das ja eher so mit Eindrücken zu machen. Wie nasser Pudel, bestellt und nicht abgeholt, dieser Look, nasser Tropf, das ist ja, klar, man kann das am Ende alles auf einer Skala verorten, gibt es bestimmt auch irgendjemand in dem Büro, der kommt morgens rein mit so einer Kaffee-Thermos-Kanne, so, morgen, morgen, morgen, du, übrigens, wir sammeln noch für Rodolpher, die hört ja leider auf jetzt am Ende. Wenn wir bei jedem Geburtstag, und das liegt daran, das Gefühl hatte, dass sie gestern erst bei mir waren. Aber wenn wir für jeden Geburtstag, ich hab so viel Geld nicht, ich verdiene so viel Geld nicht. Aber sie hat ja Geburtstag und sie verlässt uns. Sie hört ja an ihrem Geburtstag auf. Ja, hier, komm. Das heißt, es ist ja beides. Was willst du, 80 Euro? Was gehen die anderen? Die anderen haben so 120 gegeben. 120? Durchschnittlich 120.
Also Marc hat 200 gegeben, Friederike hat 800 gegeben, Paul hat zwei Euro gegeben, Jam Jam hat 140 gegeben. Der Wechselkurs ist gerade nicht optimal für mich. Unsere Frosch-Währung ist kaum noch was wert. Die Technologie-Union ist dabei, bye, bye, bye. Es kommt darauf an, wie groß dein Portemonnaie ist. Ja, aber das kann natürlich auch sein, dass irgendjemand das festlegen muss, vernünftige Zahlen eingeben wird. Wer eine Zahl verdient, ist Thomas. Denn Thomas hat uns das Intro komponiert, oder Thomas, ich weiß nicht, ob er Franzose ist. Thomas. Und er ist Thomas Nummer acht. Können wir das auch mal in eine Excel-Tabelle reinballern? Excel-Tabellen. Könnt ihr alle mal kurz auf drei euren Namen sagen, damit wir gucken, wie ein Durchschnittshörer vom Podcast. Aber was ist der Durchschnittsname, oder was willst du? Ja, der Durchschnittsname, ich würde gerne mehrere, ich bin ja seit letzter Folge, wo wir es über Excel-Tabellen hatten, in einem Excel-Tabellen-Fieber. Ja. Und seitdem möchte ich mehr Zahlen erheben. Mhmerell mehr erheben. Gar nicht zahlen. Denkt nichts in Zahlen. Excel will viel zahlen, muss nicht Zahlen eingeben. Kannst auch Wörter eingeben. Ich möchte erheben. Erhebungen machen. Daten nicht zahlen. Wörter sind auch Daten, aber es müssen nicht immer in Zahlen sein. Ihr müsst nicht zahlen. Das ist finanziell gemeint. Nee, nee, nee. Ihr müsst schon zahlen. Schon Zahlen zahlen. Ich möchte Dinge erheben, zum Beispiel, was der Durchschnittsname unserer Zuhörerschaft. Ja. Was ist der Durchschnittsalter? Welche Namen gibt es nur einmal in unserer Zuhörerschaft? Super, super. Und die kriegen alle noch einen Preis. Die kriegen alle noch was oben drauf, kriegen noch mal was aus dem Merch-Shop. Wurde man aktuell wieder Merch bestellen? Hä, hast du auch gestoßen?
Hat das Aufstossen bei dir eine Esmolze?
Das Merch ist so schön.
Ich finde es auch schön. Das Merch ist richtig schön geworden.
Der Schal ist bald wieder da.
Ja, der Schal ist leider, wir haben leider den Schal.
Der Schal ist der Renner.
Die haben mich gefragt, kurz offen, ganz offen, transparent,
die haben mich gefragt, wie viele Schals willst du?
Ich habe gesagt, komm, 200. Das ist eine Zahl, die ist rund, teilbar durch vier, fünf, zwei, acht, das Problem ist, die haben gefragt, wie viele Meter Schal wollt ihr? Also es gibt ja eine Riesenrolle Schal und dann kannst du ja, wie viel Meter wollt ihr von dieser Rolle? Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, okay, wie viel, also in Stückzahlen, klar, das ist leicht, aber wie viel Meter Schal, also wie viel Meter Schal trägt Deutschland? So schwer, ganz schwer, das in Metern zu kalkulieren. Und dann hast du halt gesagt, ja halt so, du hast die Arme so hoch gehalten und hast gesagt, na ja, so ein Stück halt. Aber jetzt ist ja meine, das ist nicht mal ein Schal. Das ist ja die Regel, die Spannweite, so lange muss der Schal sein. Gleich Körpergröße, ach so. Spannweite gleich Körpergröße, ich glaube, das hat da Vinci damals widerlegt. Spannweite gleich Körpergröße und Schalgröße nicht gleich Körpergröße. Schalgröße ist 145, habe ich jetzt gelernt. Schalgröße ist 144, unabhängig von der Körpergrösse. Es gibt eine Einheitsgrösse für Schals.
Nein, es darf keine Einheitsgrösse sein.
Ich sag nicht, wie es sein soll.
Don't hate the messenger.
Du beschreibst die Welt, wie sie ist.
Ich beschreib die Welt, wie sie sein sollte.
Ich weiß, und ich beschreib sie, wie sie ist, knallhart.
Ja, du nimmst kein Blatt vor dem Mund.
Du hast Schal vor dem Mund, aber kein Blatt vor dem Mund.
Ich hab einen Schal und meine Hand vor dem Mund.
So, und können wir da nicht einfach Hopfen und Karpfen zusammenlegen, wo er zusammengehört. Schal mit Stimmveränderung. Wir haben die Welt der Stimmveränderung schreitet mit grossen Schritten voran. Wir hatten den Kylo Ren-Helm, wo du klingst wie Kylo Jeder hat. Disney wollte, dass wir den Kylo Ren-Helm kaufen. 2024 hatte jeder den Kylo Ren-Helm. Disney hatte den Kylo Ren-Helm, Disney wollte, dass alle den Kylo Ren-Helm haben. Jeder meiner Freunde hat mich ständig angerufen. Unkuss! Jedes Mal. Jeder hatte den. Das kann jetzt subjektiv sein. Erstens, ich weiss das nicht, weil du hast keine Freunde. Zweitens, okay, ich hab ... Die klingen vielleicht alle gleich. Die klingen vielleicht alle wie Kylo Ren, aber es sind viele verschiedene Freunde, die ich habe, die mich gerne anrufen. Du wirst geprankt called. Nein, das war kein Prank, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Jeder hatte diesen Kylo Ren Helm, der dich so klingen lässt wie Kylo Ren. Weil Kylo Ren hat ja selber auch einen Kylo Ren Helm, wenn er den Helm aufhört, klingt der auch anders. Und bei dem ist auch so ein Made in China Ding drin, so ein Branding, wo Disney, Disney Corp. So ein bisschen verbogen, weil man es auf der Heizung hat
liegen lassen.
Also, wollen wir direkt mit dem Jahresrückblick
starten oder nicht? Weil für mich, deswegen wollte ich eigentlich,
das war mein grosses Finale.
Ich wollte sagen, das
Modestück des Jahres
der Kylo Renhelm, aber wird direkt
angegriffen. Ich wollte darauf raus,
Schal direkt mit dem Stimmverzerrer.
Super! Weil du hast den ja vor dem Mund. Super. Und also entweder entmuffeln, wenn du durch einen Schal sprichst, sprichst du gemuffelt, entweder entmuffeln, dass du so eine Art Portal, also dass du ein Mikrofon hast und das dann sozusagen echt wieder reinkommt. Ich mag ja diesen Look, wenn selbst die harten Kerle im Winter dann so eingemummelt und dann sieht man nicht so und dann sieht alles voll und dann die Vorstellung, dass man dann wählen kann zwischen Stimmen.
Ich kann dann wählen zwischen zum Beispiel der Synchronstimme von Daniel Craig, Daniel Deleuys, Daniel Quaid, Chair, Daniel Quaid, Dennis Quaid und zum Beispiel Claudia Schiffer.
Wir haben nicht alle
bekommen, die wir bekommen wollten für dieses
Projekt. Sie mussten leider jedes einzelne
Wort im Wörterbuch einmal sagen.
Das hat gedauert. Bono ist bis F gekommen.
Das heißt, was, wenn ihr
Wörter sagt, die jetzt nicht
mit G bis Z anfangen, dann könnt ihr auch als Bon Bonus sprechen. Neutrale Siri-Stimme würde dann sprechen in dem Fall. Die ersetzt dann jeweils die Wörter. Aber ich fände cool, wenn das Projekt heißt, das Podcast-UFO und dann haben wir einen Schal, wo wir rumschmieren und dann kannst du reden und dann kannst du währenddessen an deinem Handy mit Bluetooth kannst du die Stimme wählen. Und dann wird deine Stimme verzerrt und dann sprichst du zum Beispiel wie Smudo. Es gibt ja unterschiedliche Entmummung, Vermummung ist ja generell No-No, ist ein No-No, oder? Vermummungsverbot gilt in Deutschland, da ist natürlich der Schal gefährdet. Und es gibt ja immer so diesen klassischen, man greift mit der Hand zu unten am Hals, um sich die Maske vom
Kopf zu ziehen. Diese klassische
Gestus. Genau, der klassische Gestus.
Was ich mir gerne für 2025
wünschen würde, also wir denken jetzt an
Scooby-Doo oder so, wer steckt in der Maske?
Wir denken die ganze Zeit generell an Scooby-Doo.
Ich hätte gerne den Schal
um den Kopf gewickelt und als Enthüllungsgeste
zieht man an den Schal,
der Vermummte dreht so eine Pirouette, entdreht sich so und am Ende Blblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblbl wünschen für 2025. Ich wünsche mir mehr Freundschaft unter den Leuten. Okay, ich bin halt jetzt oft nicht da,
also ich bin leider, ich bin halt ein bisschen,
ich bin halt, ich habe das viele auch
im Wald und ich habe ja
Ich weiß, du hast dein Försterei-Projekt.
Genau, weil
ich fand, wir haben,
weil
wenn wir den Jahresrückblick machen wollen oder nicht,
dann sag gerne Bescheid, aber ich würde
gerne, weil ich habe was vorbereitet und ich würde gerne sagen, dass ich finde, dass wir 2024 zu viel Zeit miteinander verbracht haben. Ja, aber wir haben jetzt ja nichts, also außerhalb des Podcasts, nichts miteinander. Ja, aber wir sind einmal nach der Podcastaufnahme zusammen zum Parkplatz gelaufen. Ja, ja, genau. Und das, also nur ein emotionales Feedback, das war für mich so ein bisschen too much.
Das hat sich so ein bisschen klättig angefühlt, so ein bisschen zu viel. Klettig? Ja, mein Auto stand halt da, ich wollte auch nach Hause. Genau, nee, nee, nee, absolut, nee, nee, nee, nee, und das ist ja kein Vorwurf. Es ist ja nur, ich möchte einfach mal meine eigenen Gefühle, meine Emotionen darlegen. Einfach mal, ich beschreibe meine Emotionen, wie sie sind, nicht wie sie sein sollen. Ich weiß, ich botschaften.
Genau. Das sind jetzt generell sehr viele
ich-botschaften. Ich nehme kein Blatt
vor den Mund. Ich sage einfach nur die Emotionen,
wie sie ist. Und für mich war es einfach ein bisschen viel
in dem Moment, als wir
zusammen die Treppe runtergegangen sind
und dann durch die Tür gegangen
sind und dann zum Parkplatz gegangen sind.
Und da denke ich mir, das sind jetzt schon drei Sachen,
wo ich sage, lass uns ... Die gleiche Richtung. Ja, aber das heißt ja nichts. Also, nee. Wenn dich das stört, dann kannst du ja aufs Klo gehen. Du bist ja der mit der Emotion. Dann kannst du ja sagen, okay, wir sehen uns, dann tschau, geh schon mal zum Auto, ich geh noch mal kurz aufs Klo und dann müssen wir den ganzen Weg nicht gemeinsam gehen. Du gehst ja genauso mit mir zum Parkplatz wie ich mit dir. Ja, aber ich habe ja nicht den Toilettenschlüssel. Du hast ja sozusagen die Vollmacht. Ja, du kannst es nicht haben. Ja, aber dann musst du ja vor der Toilette stehen bleiben, weil ich dir danach den Toilettenschlüssel wieder zurückgeben werde. Nein, weil du einfach den Toilettenschlüssel bekommen kannst. Dann bekomm ich jetzt in Zukunft. Nee, das will ich ja auch nicht. Ich will ja auch nicht veran. Ich will ja noch weniger vor der Toilette stehen, wenn du in der Toilette bist. Du willst ja sehr viel. Du hast halt eine superkrasse Emotion. Ja, aber die versuche ich ja gerade aufzulösen. Ich kann nicht die Gefühle immer verdrängen, so wie du es immer machst. Nicht jeder ist so gut darin, seine Gefühle runterzuschlucken. Okay, das sind so Du-Botschaften. Du, Du, Du. Du machst es ja nicht. Du hast meine Ich-Botschaft zu einer Du-Botschaft gemacht. Ja, was ist denn Du-Botschaft im Fernsehen? Du hast falsch auf meine Emotion reagiert. Falsch? Ja, falsch. Vorwurf. jetzt sind wir aggressiv. Meine Emotionen, mein Empfinden. Ja, kann ich dir jetzt nicht wegnehmen. Mein Empfinden hast du objektiv falsch reagiert, ist aber meine Meinung. Nach meiner Meinung und das denken auch viele andere hast du objektiv falsch. Jetzt nennst du wirrbotschaften, jetzt nennst du empirische wirrbotschaften. Ne, es ist Statistik, das ist ja keine Meinung. Wie viel hast du befragt, wie ich mich finde? Ich habe eine Umfrage gemacht. Nein, will ich nicht sehen. Das ist verletzend. Okay, das ist dein Gefühl. Damit habe ich nichts zu tun. Ich finde es mega weird, dass du es klammernd findest, wenn man mit dir zum Auto geht. Ich wollte einfach nur sagen, ich finde, wir können ja vieles besser machen 2025. Und das ist mir eben, ich habe überlegt, was lief dieses Jahr nicht so gut. Und dann ist mir eben eingefallen, wie wir zusammen zum Parkplatz gegangen sind. Ja, aber das ist ja erst mal, hast du ja erst mal ein gutes Jahr gehabt, wenn das das Schlimmste ist. Ich hatte ein fantastisches Jahr. Ein richtig fantastisches Jahr. Aber es kommt gerade nicht an, weil du seit einem halben Zeit lang anstreist. Ein ganz fantastisches Jahr. Ich habe richtig viel Geld verdient beim Rubbellose, ich habe mein Geldeimer abgegeben, ich habe Cash, Cash, Cash in vielen kleinen Quäntchen, in vielen kleinen Summen habe ich viel Cash bekommen, wie Reis, Reisessen macht Spaß, jedes Reiskorn für sich alleine ist nichts, aber ein ganzer Topf voll Reis. Ein ganzes Universum. Ich finde es aber so lustig, dass alle inzwischen übergehend zu Ich-Botschaften senden. Die neue Streitkultur ist ja Ich-Botschaften senden, soll man ja.
Keine Du-Botschaften, nicht aggressiv sein, sondern senden alle, wie wir gerade in unserem kleinen Veranschaulichungsbild. Zu Lehrzwecken. Zu Lehrzwecken sendet man Ich-Botschaften, lernt man jetzt immer. Und ich finde das so lustig, weil das ist, erstens kann man den Leuten beim Denken zugucken, während sie Ich-Botschaften senden wollen. Es sind so, ich nenne es jetzt immer böse, kurz mal, ich werde kurz böse die nächsten paar Minuten, okay? Zu Lehrzweck. Es sind diese durchtherapierten Arschlochpaare, die dann vielleicht doch nicht so durchtherapiert sind und dann so mega fucking passiv-aggressiv miteinander reden beide wissen so, wie man streitet und dann und es ist viel schlimmer, dadurch wird es viel schlimmer weil alle in diesen Ich-Botschaften den anderen bis in den Mark fertig machen und dann aber das Vokabular haben, damit es dann nicht ganz eskaliert dadurch bildet sich aber so eine Bubble in der viel mehr eskaliert wird und irgendwie dann sagen sie so, wie gerade, im Anschaulichungsbeispiel, dann so was wie, ja, du bist einfach der schlimmste Mensch der Welt, verklausuliert in meiner Meinung, ich finde das, bei mir kommt es halt so an, dass du das grösste Arschloch bist. Genau. Bist du vielleicht nicht, aber bei mir kommt es halt so an. Du bist ein narzisstisches Arschloch, sondern ich habe den Eindruck, ich habe das Gefühl, bei mir kommt es so an, als wärst du ein Das darfst du nicht sagen, du? Deswegen meine ich, clevere Leute kriegen das ja dann. Dann sei ich Stefan, oder was? Bei mir kommt es so an, jetzt sei Stefan. Nee, es geht nicht um Semantik, es geht um die Botschaft. Bei mir kommt es halt so an, als würde ich mit einem narzisstischen Arschloch zu tun haben. Viel zu lange schon zusammen sein. Aha, okay, das klingt besser. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, und dann merkt man das, dann gehört man das dann und dann denkt man, oh, das ist vielleicht noch schlimmer. Ich respektiere deine Meinung, ich würde sie gerne noch durch meine Meinung ergänzen. Durch meine bessere Meinung. Ich würde sie durch meine Meinung gerne noch aufwerten. Genau. Ich würde sie gerne überschreiben durch meine Meinung. Weil was ist denn Streiten im Kern? Ist doch wie so, es muss sich kurz was entladen. Man ist so lange hockt man aufeinander, kleine Dinge stauen sich an, kleine Dinge müssen sich kurz pressen, so wie so ein Teilchenbeschleunter, stell ich mir das vor, so gegeneinander und dann platzt kurz und dann wird kurz darüber gestritten und Emotionen kommen raus und manchmal geht es ja gar nicht so sehr um die Sache, sondern mehr um da mal kurz Luft rauszulassen und dann ist wieder gut.
Ich habe mich nicht gestritten dieses Jahr, glaube ich.
Ich weiß.
Ich habe ganz wenig, also ich glaube, ich könnte das gar nicht, weil ich finde, was du beschreibst, dieses übertherapierte Pärchen, die können sehr gut streiten, die haben alle zehn Punkte in Streiten.
Die haben alle Tools. Ist das denn das Ziel, dass man sehr gut streiten kann, weil ich finde, was du beschreibst, dieses übertherapierte Pärchen, die können sehr gut streiten, die haben alle zehn Punkte in Streiten. Ist das denn das Ziel, dass man sehr gut streiten kann, weil ich glaube, ich komme nicht in Streits, weil ich kann es nicht, ich weiß nicht, also angenommen, das ist so, ich stelle mir das vor, du lebst neben einem Tennisplatz und dann hauen die den Ball so über das Netz und dann landet der Ball bei dir und du weißt überhaupt nicht, was du tun sollst, du kannst das Spiel nicht spielen, deswegen legst du den Tennisball dann wieder in so einen Korb. Aber kann ich dich fragen? Und du kannst ihn nicht zurückschlagen. Und so ist es bei mir auch, wenn Streit bei mir ankommt. Das ist wie wenn jemand ein Frisbee so, ach, und dann, ich weiss, oh, sorry, wie soll ich den halten, ich weiss gar nicht, und dann passiert auch nichts. Mit dir streite ich mich ja auch nie. Aber es gibt ja Menschen, mit denen du dich streitest. Nee. Aber warum ... Ich streite mich nur mit mir selber oder mit anonymen Leuten im Internet, mit denen ich dann imaginäre Streits in meinem Kopf führe. Aber dann meine ich vielleicht auch einfach genau dich mit diesem Beispiel. Oh. Das war jetzt aber eine Dich-Botschaft. Ja, jetzt hör mal zu, du Wichser, kurz. Ganz habe ich noch nicht verstanden, was das bringen soll. Weil ich glaube nämlich, du streitest ja dann auch, du nennst es nur anders. Na, was heißt Streit? Zum Beispiel habe ich letztens ... Emotional diskutieren. Wo ich oft Schwierigkeiten habe, ist, wir sind beide große Verfechter von Carsharing angeboten. Und dann habe ich ein Carsharing-Auto etwas frech geparkt. Passiert manchmal dicht beparkte Stadt, man findet nicht alles. So, und dann hab ich direkt hinter einem Wohnwagen geparkt. Und wirklich sehr knapp. Also das war wirklich so ein Austin Powers Zentimeter-Rangieren. War das nötig, dass es so knapp war? Es war absolut nötig, weil das mache ich auch manchmal auch Spaß für diesen Autos. Für mich sind die wie so Autoscooter. Ja, absolut. Ich nehme die eher wahr wie
Autoscooter, es sind vollwertige Autos,
aber ich nehme sie eher wahr wie so Go-Karts
als wie Autos. Ja, das stimmt.
Der reine Fakt, dass man sich einfach reinsetzen
kann und brumm brumm machen kann
und dass jeder machen kann,
macht es weg, hebt es
einen Autostatus. Ja, absolut. Es ist wie
so ein Wegwerfauto, wo man sagt, egal.
Und dann habe ich wirklich so zehn Zentimeter hinter dem Auto davor geparkt, also nicht die feine Art. Aber ich dachte mir, es ist ein Wohnmobil. Damit fährst du nicht jeden Tag zum Bäcker so. Damit Du versprichst dich auch manchmal. Stefan, Stefan, Stefan. Deutlicher reden, deutlicher reden, deutlicher reden. Perfekt. Es war ein Wohnmobil. Ich kenne den Unterschied. Stefan, ich bin in meiner Kindheit einmal im Jahr zur Karawan- und Bootmesse gegangen und habe mir Karawane und Boote angeschaut.
Was sind denn ...
Und da gibt es auch Wohnmobil und Wohnwagen.
Und wenn ich eins kenne ...
Stopp, stopp, stopp.
Ich finde, wir werden immer besser im Streiten.
Und ich kenne den Unterschied zwischen Wohnmobil und Wohnwagen.
Die, die mal irgendwo gehört haben, die in seinem Lehrbuch gelernt haben, was das ist. Ich kenne den Unterschied und deswegen meine ich Wohnmobil, wenn ich Wohnwagen sage. Einmal eine Wortmeldung, Stefan. Genau, Frage. Und zwar, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Caravan, Wohnmobil, Wohnwagen, Wohnwagenanhänger und Camper? Wohnwagenanhänger gibt es nicht. Wenn es ein Anhänger ist, ist es ein Wohnwagen. Wenn man es selber fahren kann, dann ist es ein Wohnmobil. Macht der Sinn. Wohnwagen hängst du, spann den Wagen an, hey ho, hinten an dein Auto ran. Karavan. Ja genau, ein Karavan. Nein, nicht ja genau sagen, was ist ein Karavan? Ein Karawan ist halt ein bisschen grösser. Oh mein Gott, albern. Du weißt gar nichts. Wir reden aber nicht von dem Katamann. Karawan ist die übergeordnete Bezeichnung für alles, sagen wir mal. Du hast es selbstbewusst vorgetragen. Dann halt dieses Schulterzucken hat mich so ein bisschen rausgeholt. Aber okay. Na gut, auf jeden Fall, es war ein Wohnmobil, 10 cm da hinten habe ich geparkt, ich musste ein bisschen was ausladen, hat ein bisschen länger gedauert, plötzlich kommt ein lächerlich kleines Auto, angerauscht, ein lächerlich kleines Auto, wirklich Hochgeschwindigkeit, steht direkt davor, jemand steigt auf, Ein kleiner Mann. Ich kann ja nicht parken!
Ich habe ja gewagt!
Ein relativ grosser, kräftiger Mann steigt auf und sagt,
ist das Ihr Auto hier?
So, Wohnmobilbesitzer.
Moment, bist du noch, wurdest du in Flagrant hier erwischt?
Ich wurde in Flagrant hier erwischt.
Weil das Schöne bei solchen Mietwagen ist ja immer,
dass man sagen kann, nee, ich will ja gerade entsperren.
Nee, ich hatte keine Chance,
ich hatte gerade wirklich einen Kasten Diebels. Einen Kasten Bibeln? Ich hatte eine Kiste Bibeln. Bibels Bier. Ach so, ich dachte, Kasten Bibeln. Also sagen wir mal, als Beispiel, ich hatte eine Kiste Bibeln, hatte ich gerade in der Hand. Nee, das Beispiel macht das jetzt alles schwieriger, weil auf so jemanden würde man anders reagieren. Ist es, glaube ich, schon jetzt hilfreich, wenn wir dir was geben. Man hat von außen nicht gesehen, dass Bibeln in der Kiste sind. Okay. So, habe ich in der Hand, Kofferraum offen, so. Mund und Kofferraum offen. Genau, und dann mein Mund, Kofferraum, Hosenstein offen. So, das ist die Situation, der Typ kommt an und deutet so auf die zehn Zentimeter, also den Abstand, meinte so, ja, also was ist das hier, so geht's doch nicht. Und dann meinte ich so, ja, aber sie haben ja vorne ganz viel Platz, der kann ja ohne weiteres wegfahren, weil sie haben ja vorne Platz, sie fahren nicht rückwärts. Und dann meinte er, ja, da kann ja morgen einer stehen. Und dann habe ich gefragt, planen Sie denn morgen, Ihr Wohnmobil zu fahren? Nee, aber aus Prinzip. Dann meinte ich, okay, aber das hier ist ein Carsharing-Auto, das ist ja eh bald weg, dann können Sie wieder rausfahren. Nee, das müssen Sie jetzt umparken. Hin und her, hin und her, ich natürlich, wie in Streitsituationen, lege mich sofort mit dem Rücken auf den Boden, sage, okay, ja, ich fahahr weg, kein Problem. Und dann meint er, ja, aber hier, so zu parken
ist schon ein bisschen assi.
Und dann sag ich, assi würde ich
jetzt nicht sagen,
aber ich fahr gerne weg,
mach ich jetzt kein Problem.
Und das war, glaube ich, das Näheste
an einem Streit,
dass ich gesagt habe, also, das nehme ich
nicht an, den Vorwurf, ich fahr gerne
weg, wenn sie das wollen, aber assi nehme ich nicht an, das ist nicht Asi.
Pass auf, also, ich kenne dich ja. Und wir hatten auch schon gerade so im Kreativen hitzige Diskussionen.
Ja, da schon, auf jeden Fall, ja.
Und ich bin der Meinung, und das fand ich spannend, weil wir sind da sehr nah beieinander oft.
Aber dann gab es trotzdem manchmal so Sachen, die wir ganz anders gesehen haben und so.
Und dann sind wir auch nicht abgerügt davon. weil wir sind da sehr nah beieinander oft. Aber dann gab es trotzdem manchmal so Sachen, die wir ganz anders gesehen haben und so.
Und dann sind wir auch nicht abgerüht davon.
Und jetzt sag ich dazu Streit, du sagst dazu nicht Streit.
Ich glaube auch, weil du gerne an dieser Legende feststellst,
dass du nie streitest.
Nee, aber ich glaube, das war das Streitigste, wo ich ...
Ich sage ja, ich entwickle mich zum Streiter.
Nee, das ist ein Streit.
Und jetzt in dem Moment sage ich ... Du benutzt nur ... Wie du etwas sagst, jetzt gerade erzählst du das nach und es klingt nicht wie ein Streit, aber ich weiss ja, was du dann für ein Gesicht ziehst, wenn du sagst ... Wie offen er mutig ist. Das will ich jetzt nicht sagen. Und genau wie du das sagst, das meinst du genau wie dieses therapeutische Pärchen. Bei dir kann ich ja mehr entladen, bei dem Fremden auf der Strasse. Und da würde ich sagen, das wäre für mich die Schwelle zum Streit gewesen, zu sagen, Assi nicht, das gebe ich Ihnen nicht. Wenn ich da gesagt hätte, ja, Sie haben recht, Entschuldigung, so. Aber da ging es für mich in den Streit über, deswegen würde ich sagen, ich hatte einen Streit dieses Jahr, ich möchte mich korrigieren, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, sorry, Entschuldigung, I apologize. Sondern da, glaube ich, wurde es kurz zu einem Streit, auch wenn der Streit nur ganz kurz ging. Entschuldigung, Daddyigung, Daddy. Entschuldigung, Daddy. Ich sage, nee, Assi nicht, das nehme ich nicht an, aber ich bin trotzdem weggefahren. Und seitdem steht dieses Wohnmobil jeden Tag noch genau an derselben Stelle. Es kommen und gehen Autos davor und danach. Ganz ähnliche Situation, und ich habe es ganz anders gehandhabt. Car-Sherry-Auto geparkt neben einen Container. Da war offensichtlich so eine Art Renovation am Start und da war ein Container vorm Haus. Und da war auch ein Schild ab dem 12.12. irgendwie Parkverbot. Und es war am Abend des 12. oder so, also so knapp, und da war dann neben ein Parkplatz frei. Und da habe ich mich hingestellt mit dem Karschengel und dachte, das ist auch bald weg. Und dann war dieser Container da, ich dachte mir, gut, ja, ich verstehe schon, warum man da das sperrt, weil wenn er abgeholt wird, da kommen ja so zwei Greifarme neben dem Container hoch und ich habe das Auto direkt daneben geparkt. Und dann kam der Typ raus, hat den beladen und hat dann gesagt, ja, ist halt Parkverbot, ne?
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber müssen Sie den heute noch weg damit?
Ja, nee, aber ich belade den heute die ganze Zeit.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, okay, also soll ich jetzt wegfahren?
Ja, müssen Sie ja wissen.
Okay, also muss ich jetzt den wegfahren oder nicht, weil der wird ja gleich genommen.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, keine Ahnung, aber ich belade das Auto ja noch ein bisschen länger, ne?
Das war's für heute. okay, also muss ich jetzt den wegfahren oder nicht, weil der wird ja gleich genommen.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ja keine Ahnung, aber ich belade das Auto hier noch ein bisschen länger, ne,
den Container noch ein bisschen länger, meinend, es könnte was, was er da reinwirft, der auch zufällig auf dem Auto landen.
Ach, okay, aber ist das jetzt eine Du- oder eine Ich-Botschaft, wenn du das als Drohung wahrnimmst?
Der Typ war so assi drauf, durch, ich glaube, diese schwere Arbeit, die er da gerade verrichtet hat. Und dann habe ich, als er dann weg war, gesagt, wie kann man nur so ein Assi sein? Ah, okay, spannend, wie unterschiedlich mit diesem Wort auch umgehen ist. Und wieso wohnt man in Köln, wenn man so ist,ieso das denn? Und dann bin ich ab und umgeparkt. Wo kam das denn her? Ich sage ja, ich gehe anders mit sowas um. Warum wohnt man in Köln, wenn man sich darüber ärgert, dass Leute im Halteverbot parken? Nee, wenn man so ein Wichser ist. Also das kannst du in Hannover machen, aber nicht in Köln. In Köln, die Mentalität in Köln. Der Grund, warum ich überhaupt mit dem Dialog getreten bin, ist, weil ich Köln so wahrnehme,
dass man mit dem spricht, so, ja,
ist es okay, wenn ich hier kurz parke, ist der hier gleich
weg, außerdem wollen sie den Container erst
morgen abholen lassen wahrscheinlich. Dann sagt er,
ja, komm, park da. So kenne ich Köln.
Das ist mein Köln. Ja. Und dass
dann jemand aber so reagiert, da habe ich irgendwie
initiativ gedacht,
das passt überhaupt nicht in diese Stadt, dieses
Gespräch, was wir hier gerade haben. Ja, das ist eine... Und dann habe ich ihm gesagt, wie kann man denn in Köln wohl, wenn man so ist? Und bin weggefahren. War ich umgeparkt. Wo meinst du, wäre der Glückliche? Was wäre eine Stadt für pedantische Leute? Ja, okay. Wo wohnst du? Da. Aber das ist, und ich weiß nicht, wann du zum Jahresrückblick überleiten willst, anscheinend nicht jetzt, aber möchte ich, weil ich habe am Ende noch so ein Fazit, was ich mir wünsche für 2025, kann ich jetzt kurz anbringen.
Da können wir ein paar Prognosen raushauen fürs nächste Jahr.
Ah, vielleicht nimmt die Inflation zu, ah, vielleicht das Kinosterben weiter, ein paar deiner prägnanten Florentin-Zukunftsprognosen.
Nee, sondern mir ging es eher um ...
Ah, die Klimaerwärmung geht wahrscheinlich weiter voran. Ah, wir tun wahrscheinlich weiterhin zu wenig für den Ausbau von erneuerbaren Energien. So eine Florentin-Thesen. Nee, mir ging es eher um Wunsch für 2025. Und zwar geht es ... Ich schlag genau in deine Kerbe. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass das Konzept Carsharing mehr in der breiten Bevölkerung ankommt, im Sinne von, der ist ja eh gleich weg.
Ich komme irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
halb elf Uhr abends nach Hause,
parktes Auto,
vor einer Gehsteigung,
vor der Polizeirevier.
So, und ich bin, boah, Gott, Leute.
So, und es war, ich weiß, ich kenne das Wort nicht. Es war wie eine Einfahrt, aber nicht für Autos, sondern für Menschen. Eingangsbereich. Ja, es war, ja, Eingang klingt so blöd, aber es war wie so ein Weg, den man nimmt. Klingt so blöd? Ja, weil damit ja ein Eingang in Haus gemeint ist oder so. Ich meine, es war schon so eine Art Einfahrt, aber halt kleiner für Menschen. Wie so ein Zaungatter, das aufgeht und dann geht so ein Weg zu dem Haus. Aber da kannst du ja vorparken. So, und hab ich da... Genau, hab ich da geparkt. Da muss ja kein Auto rein, kein Problem. So, dann gehe ich nach Hause, hundsmiserabel müde, ja, zieh mir direkt. Was soll denn da los?
Zieh mir direkt, ach ja, Mensch, war ein harter Tag im Büro, ich musste wieder Excel-Tabellen
ausfüllen.
Und dann ziehe ich mir schön mein Nachthemd an, lege mich ins Bett, zack klingelt das
Handy, am anderen Ende Service Provider dieses Carsharing sagt, wir wurden gerade informiert,
dass sie da in einer privaten Einfahrt stehen, der Anrufer hat gedroht, sie abschleppen zu lassen. Wollen sie das Auto jetzt noch umparken? Nehmen wir mal. Geh da noch mal hin. Ganz kurz, was für ein Megaservice ist das denn? Ist ein geiler Service. Normalerweise bist du einfach abgeschleppt und tschüss. Der Fakt, dass die dich, weil die haben ja eh keine Kosten, die trägst du ja komplett, plus Bearbeitungsgebühr. Das heißt aber, dass der Bewohner dieses Auto gesehen hat, gecheckt hat, dass es ein Carsharing-Auto ist, gecheckt hat, für welcher Firma alles verstanden, um da anzurufen. Dann aber auch die Energie und Zeit hatte, da in der Warteschleife sich verbinden zu lassen, das würde ich ja schon nicht drauf kommen. Aber ich denke mir, wenn du so viel verstanden hast, dann musst du doch auch verstehen, dass es in einer Stunde weg ist. Und das ist halb elf. Ist doch scheißegal, ob jemand vor deinem, also da war noch der Gehsteig dazwischen, ne? Alles cool, so. Ich hab niemanden behindert. Es gibt da, es war einfach nur ein, das ist mein Privatding, so. Das ist einfach, ich versteh nicht. Ich muss aber sagen, es ist gleich weg. Sternchen? Genau. Im Zweifel nicht. Aber auch dann Doppelsternchen? Aber auch dann dauert es nicht so lange. Sternchen? Im Zweifel doch. Weil Gegenthese in der transparente Podcast, wir sind umgezogen in Köln. Der gläserne Podcast, ja. Wir sind Podcast, wir sind umgezogen in Köln im Studio. Ich habe einen grossen Transporter gemietet von Milfs und habe den dann abgestellt. Ich bin wirklich so lange rumgekurvt, dass ich schon so Tränen in den Augen hatte. Und da werde ich, ich bin recht ... Weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich das noch ... Man kann auch zu seinen Emotionen stellen. Absolut. Ich bin ein emotionaler Kerl. Jetzt nicht aufbrausend, aber ich weine. Du hast auch nicht geweint, du hattest nur Tränen in den Augen. Es war wirklich so eine Zwiebelsituation. Du warst einfach nur weich und du hast so geleckt. Ich habe richtig Rotz und Wasser geheult, weil ich keinen Parkplatz ... Okay, aber gut, das respektiere ich, das verstehe ich auch. Absolut. Parkplatz ist schrecklich. Nein, weiß ich. Aber er war schon so rumgeschrien und so. Nein, nein, ich will nicht sein. Und dann habe ich einen gefunden, er war auf der Firma, bei einer Firma, auf so einem Firmenparkplatz. Habe den draufgestellt, bei mir in der Nähe, Firmenparkplatz, und dann gedacht, ja, Florentins Gedanke, ich bin dann bald weg, ich bin dann mal weg auf den Autos und dann war der den ganzen nächsten Tag noch da. Und da habe ich gedacht, jetzt gleich ist er einfach, wird abgeschleppt und dann tschüss. Dann habe ich mich gefragt, kann man überhaupt so einen Riesentransporter abschleppen? Da habe ich mir einen Riesentransporter-Abschlepper vorgestellt. Dann dachte ich mir, was wenn der mal im Halteverbot steht. Stimmt, ja. Wie gross? Und dann habe ich in Star Wars Episode 1 mal wieder gedacht, there is always a bigger fish. Dann dachte ich mir, was ist das grösste abschleppende Fahrzeug? In der Zeit hätte ich den easy umparken können, aber ich war dann gedanklich bei, was ist das grösste abschleppende Fahrzeug? Meinend auch, was ist das grösste noch abschleppbare Fahrzeug? Sehr gute Frage. Man sieht ja manchmal auf der Autobahn gerade nachts so Schwerlasttransporte, die dann über mehrere Spuren so ein riesiges Rotorblatt von so einer Windmaschine, von so einem, wie heißt es? Turbine. Von so einem Grasrad, wie heißt es denn? Windrad. Windrad, von so einem Windrad, wo ich mir immer denke, oh Gott, bitte hab keine Panne, ey, bitte hab jetzt denkst du für das Auto? Ja, ich denke mir,
bitte hab jetzt keine Panne, weil stell dir vor,
der liegt da am Seitenstreifen, steht
diese Windradturbine und dann kommt der
ADAC mit so kratzig so am Kopf
und so, ne, ich glaube die ADAC-Autos,
diese
gelben Brecher,
diese kleinen gelben Panzer,
die sind, glaube ich, die ziehen alles aus so
ein Windturbinenrad, die haben doch 1800 PS, ja, aber das ist so ein Tourareg oder nicht. Das ist ein Tourareg, aber so aufgemobbelt mit 1500 Sachen. Die ziehen dir alles raus. Die ziehen dir alles weg, ich glaube, die können das. Die ziehen im Zweifel, nehmen die dieses Windrad und werfen das da oben ran. Ja, so schön aufs Dach einfach aufgespannt mit so schönen Expander-Dingern. Aber das, finde ich, ist ein Bewusstsein, das gehört noch in die Bevölkerung. Ich weiß nicht, ich denke an eine Flyer-Kampagne, ich denke an Lautsprecher. Auf diesen Dingern sollte man einfach unten, da steht ja dann oft irgendwie so Carsharing leicht gemacht oder keine Ahnung, Spring rein, fahr weg, hop on, hop off und da drunter schreibst du einfach, ich bin gleich weg. Eine letzte Idee, pass auf, und zwar es führt nur dazu, dass Leute Feuerwehreinfahrten zu parken. Ja, ja, ja, ich denke mir so, also es gibt eine, wenn du die Miete beendest, dann hast du noch so einen Knopf von so einer Chilischote. Heißt, ich habe spicy geparkt. Heisses Eisen.
Ich habe spicy geparkt.
Ja.
Und es bedeutet, und wenn du dann wiederum nach verfügbaren Autos suchst in der App, dann siehst du die Chilischote bei Autos. Oh, spicy geparkt. Ich habe spicy geparkt. Und wenn jemand das dann mietet, dann zahlst du für den Nächsten die ersten zehn Minuten der Fahrt. So dass der eine Motivation hat, schnell die Spicy-Park-Autos wegzunehmen und du sagst, ah, ich parke hier Spicy, dafür zahle ich ein bisschen was von der nächsten Fahrt. Win, win, win. Alle haben gewonnen, weil die sofort priorisiert weggefahren werden. Nachteil, du parkst Feuerwehreinfahrten zu. Also das ist ja dann natürlich, die Frage ist, wo ist das Limit der Spiciness? Also, ich denke jetzt wirklich nicht an Parkverbot, sondern halt an, ja, mein Gott, hier ist halt, es ist ein Spielplatz. Ich gebe dir 10 Euro, gebe ich dir, für jede Situation, die dir einfällt, die dazu da runterfallen würde, ohne dass es illegal ist. Weil, ä glaube, das gibt es nicht. Entweder du parkst wirklich jemanden komplett zu, darf man nicht, darf man nicht. Es gibt ja Situationen, wo du so eine Parkreihe hast und dann gibt es dann am Ende noch irgendwie so einen gestreiften Bereich oder so. Ja, ja, klar, aber ist verboten. Ja, technisch gesehen ist es verboten, aber du behinderst ja trotzdem niemanden. Wie gesagt, es ist spicy, es ist ein bisschen spicy. Und du gehst natürlich das Risiko ein, dass wenn du erwischt wirst, musst du doppelt zahlen, weil du wusstest, dass es spicy war. Du kannst nicht mehr sagen. Ich packe sehr oft spicy und sehr, sehr gern spicy. Ja, aber ich wurde auch dieses Jahr abgeschleppt, muss ich auch sagen.
Abgeschleppt? Ich wurde abgeschleppt wirklich und dann merkt man schon auch, okay, da nicht mehr. Das stimmt schon, das hat schon seinen Lerneffekt. Aber dieser Typ, dieser Wohnmobiltyp, dass der auch mit seinem kleinen Auto angerauscht kam. Das heißt, der sitzt in seinem Haus, das so weit weg ist, dass man mit dem Auto fahren muss, kann aber trotzdem noch diese zehn Zentimeter Parklücke sehen. Du sagst die ganze Zeit, ein kleines Auto, kleines Auto. Das war so fucking klein. Sagt das aus so einer SUV-Sicht? Das war so fucking klein. Nee, das war nicht klein. Das war smart. Es war wirklich wie so ein Einsatz. Also wie so ein, ich muss da wirklich schnell hin. Es war so ein Wusler. Das hat wahrscheinlich auch nur eine Reichweite von 500 Metern, aber es ist wirklich, das ist wie so ein Auto, wo du so eine Kurbel aufkurbeln musst mit so einem Gummiband und damit fährt das. Und es kann aber auch nicht weiterfahren als die Kraft, die du durch das Gummiband speicherst, es hat keinen Motor im klassischen Sinne. Und dann hast du betont, dass ein grosser, starker Mann ausgestiegen ist. Ja, relativ kräftiger Mann, Daunenjacke und stürmt auf mich zu. Und wie ernst hast du den genommen? Ich habe den sehr ernst genommen. Ich ja nicht, weil Leute mit kleinen Autos. Also das Ding ist, ich weiß nicht, was mein Punkt ist. Dieser Mann war ein Erwartungssandwich, weil erste Erwartungsschicht ist ein Urlauber, der hat ein Wohnmobil, das ist ein entspannter Typ.
Nee, erste Erwartung mit dem Auto und Klauen.
Richtig, aber bevor ich ihn gesehen habe, wusste ich, er hat ein Wohnmobil, das war in meinem Kopf schon, was habe ich für einen Menschen vor mir. Ein Wohnmobil denke ich immer, entspannter Rentner, Campingplatz, locker mal nach Italien, jetzt ist gerade Winter, jetzt steht das Ding nur rum, kein Problem. Dann kam er angefangen, dann wieder, oh,
kleines Auto,
flitzig unterwegs, vielleicht nur so eine spritzige Rentnerin oder sowas.
Nicht im klassischen Sinne ein Sandwich,
kein wirklich gutes Sandwich. Wir haben Brot, Brot
und dann
am Ende kam er raus
und ich dachte, okay, das bricht jetzt meine
komplette Erwartung. Es ist Brot, Brot, Wurst.
Ich nehme mir vor, dass das Auto so Schlangenlinien-mäßig gefahren ist.
Ja, es ist also fast so, als würde man rechts die Tür aufmachen und mit dem Bein so antreiben, das Auto.
Das Auto war so klein, dass es wirklich fast schon ein Sportgerät war.
Und ja, wir haben uns dann getrennt, ich musste umparken, habe ewig keinen Parkplatz gefunden.
Aber das war so ein Ding, wo ich mir wirklich dachte, assi ist es nicht. Das war die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, getrennt, ich musste umparken, habe ewig keinen Parkplatz gefunden, aber das war so ein Ding, wo ich mir wirklich dachte, assi ist es nicht, das lasse ich mir nicht gefallen und ich glaube, das hat der Florentin vor 18 Jahren anders geregelt. Wie? Einfach klein, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, es tut mir so leid, ich fahre sofort weg, wollen Sie noch meine Bibeln geschenken? Dass du deine Veränderung positiv feststellst, wo ich sage, die Änderung ist so klein, also du hast vorher …
Ja. Wollen Sie noch meine Bibeln geschenken? Krass, dass du deine Veränderung positiv feststellst, wo ich sage, die Änderung ist so klein. Also du hättest vorher ... Ja, aber keine Erinnerung, jede Lawine beginnt mit einem kleinen Schneekördelchen, sage ich ja immer gerne. Wut ist ein Ausdruck von etwas löst sich, habe ich gelernt. Aha, okay. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ganz gut. Das heisst, angenommen, du stehst im Stau, nichts geht voran, alles klemmt, alles zuckelt und du bist stockwütend, was genau löst sich dann? Nee, eher so, du, also Wut kann auch ein Ausdruck sein von, du löst dich gerade zum Beispiel von einem blöden Gedanken, den du aus deiner Kindheit mit rumschleppst oder so. Und dann kann Wut ein Outlet sein, was signalisiert, tatsächlich macht dein Kopf gerade Schritte. Ich will dich nicht wutrechtfertigen oder unnötigen Road Rage. Aber da zum Beispiel hast du ja auch schon, da hast du ja diese Emotionen, die du brauchst für den saftigen Streit. Du hast gesagt, du hast Leute
angeschrien aus dem Auto heraus.
Also immer in deinem sicheren
Rahmen, in deinem faradäischen Käfig.
Die Blase.
Die Blase, aber da hast du ja alles,
alle Bauteile, die du für einen geilen Streit
brauchst, hast du ja. Du musst nur
die Scheibe runtermachen. Ja, habe ich letztens
beobachtet, in Essen tatsächlich.
Wir waren ja in Essen unterwegs und
da habe ich tatsächlich beobachtet, wie vor
mir ein Auto fährt
und Scheibe runtermachen. Ja, habe ich letztens beobachtet in Essen tatsächlich. Wir waren ja in Essen unterwegs und da habe ich tatsächlich beobachtet, wie vor mir ein Auto fährt und ein anderes Auto fährt daneben, hält wie bei Red Dead Redemption, da kann man so die Geschwindigkeit halten, um sich mit dem Reiter nebenan zu unterhalten und genauso auch und dann haben die beide Fenster runter gemacht und haben diskutiert aus den Autos raus, relativ langsam gefahren, die hinter dem Auto alle gestaut, aber niemand hat es gewagt, zu hupen oder irgendwas zu machen, weil man wusste, hier liegt eine Schlägerei in der Luft. Weil man kann allein an den gestikulierenden Armen sehen, da ist Bizeps vorhanden, da sind Tattoos drauf, da sind Schlagringe an, also das war wirklich so eine Situation, hier geht's gleich rund und niemand wollte mit Kollateralschaden werden. Es gibt dieses geile Video in Miami, wo irgendwie ein Fahrer sucht Parkplatz oder sowas, das ist langsam mehr, von hinten kommt jemand und hupt und ich glaube, die haben sich schon, das Video beginnt da erst, ich glaube, die haben davor schon sich gestritten, weil die Reaktion, die jetzt kommt, suggeriert das ein bisschen, dass da schon mehr passiert ist, weil der Mann steigt aus, springt hoch und macht so einen Karate-Move und trennt den Seitenspiegel, den Rückspiegel ab. Und er springt so hoch, aber er ist nicht der klassische sportliche Karate-Tekken-Guy, sondern der Sprung sieht so aus, als wäre er nicht nötig gewesen, weil er macht eigentlich nur diese er haut den Seitenspiegel ab ich glaube, die sind einfach nur dran geklebt mit Plastik, so, man kann die einfach abbrechen mit einem schönen Faustschlag aber er ist davor so hochgesprungen hat ihn dann so, das ist auch wie so ein Videokarakter, wie so Roadrunner-mäßig, geil und ist dann wieder eingestiegen und weggefahrengefahren. Und da hat auch niemand gewagt, die jetzt zu ... Nein, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Weil natürlich nicht, du willst nicht reingezogen werden. Du willst nicht auch deinen Kopf noch so abgejobbt bekommen, mit so einem Sprung, zack. Das ist so ein lustiges Video. Geil. Ein Sprung und vielleicht auch noch so eine kleine Pirouette. Einfach mal so eine Drehung und dann Bapp, du kriegst ja Bonus-Damage. Hattest du du jeweils einen Unfall? Ich hatte tatsächlich einen kleinen Unfall, und zwar war das tatsächlich bei einem ersten Date, würde ich sagen. Bei einem ersten Date, also es war so eine Situation, wo man sich schon so, wo man schreibt, schreibt, schreibt, telefoniert und dann trifft man sich mal gemeinsam. Und dann sind wir gefahren, auch ein Stück und wirklich die Fahrt, das war wirklich so nach ein paar Minuten direkt angedotzt mit einem anderen Auto. So klassisch Spurwechsel, toter Winkel, nicht richtig gesehen, dotzt ran. Und es war wirklich so der schlechtmöglichste Eindruck, den man
überhaupt machen kann, wo man sich denkt, okay, schreiben, telefonieren geht, aber sobald man mal zusammen ist, einfach sofort Katastrophe und dann denke ich mir aber, habe ich es ganz gut gelöst, weil dann habe ich es mit dem Typen, weil dann so, okay, alles klar, ja, man sieht nichts, alles klar, okay, ja, wie ist das jetzt, na, machen wir was, ja, so, komm, ich geb dir 50 Euro.
Was? Ich hab 50
Euro gegeben. Was? Das wirkt mir etwas, was so weit weg von dir ist. Ja, ich weiß, es war wahrscheinlich auch so ein Testosteron-Moment oder so ein Moment, dass ich muss jetzt hier einfach die raus aus. Fünfmal 50 Euro? Einfach so ein, entweder ist ein Schaden da oder nicht. Und wenn ein Schaden da ist,
kommst du mit 50 Euro nirgendwo hin.
Nee, nee, es war einfach nur,
für mich war das so ein Impuls,
werd den los, gib dem schnell
was, damit es sich löst. Der ist wahrscheinlich
unzufrieden, wenn er nur mit einem Handschlag geht.
Gib dem irgendwas. Ich habe hier
ein Date im Auto. Guck, ich gebe dir
50 Euro und will vergessen die Sache.
Ah, okay, hätte man auch gut sagen können. 50 Euro passt, Handschlag drauf, wieder eingestiegen, weitergefahren. Ich weiß nicht, dass die Menschen in der Welt sind, die Menschen in der Welt sind, die Menschen in der Welt sind, die gelaufen danach? Ja, das wäre natürlich eine längere Geschichte mit Höhen und Tiefen. Wir haben Lust und Zeit. Wir haben das ganze Jahr 2025 Zeit, aber ist schon was draus geworden, natürlich, wie bewertet man sowas letzten Endes, aber alles in Ordnung. Vielleicht hat es sogar Bonuspunkte gegeben, aber das war wirklich unangenehm, wie das einfach sofort, wenn die Person denkt ja, die kennt ja nur fünf Minuten aus seinem Leben und schliesst von diesen fünf Minuten auf alle anderen fünf Minuten deines Lebens. Der hat ständig Unfälle. Anscheinend ist er sehr reich, weil er löst die mit Geld, also er besticht. Wo seid ihr dann hingefahren? Zu Ikea. Wirklich? Ja. Dann so da gegessen, Köttbuller reingeballert. Ikea ist ein gutes Date. Ist immer so, Ikea ist mega. War mal so eine Zeit, da war das beliebt. Inzwischen macht man das eher selten. Die Frage ist, wie pedantisch ist man an der Fleischbällchentheke? Sagt man Shirtbullar? Ach Gott, nein. Was die korrekte Aussprache. Mein Problem ist ja mit, also wir haben ja Pedanterie, ist ja hier immer immer ein Thema. Mein Problem ist, ich weiss oft, weil ich so unendlich schlau bin oder weil ich so oft korrigiert werde, mein Problem ist fast, wenn du das Richtige weisst, dann geht das Problem erst los. Weil ich bin nicht jemand, der sagt, ah, mit die Schottbüller bitte, ah, mit die Schottbülle bitte. Das kann ich nicht machen, weil ich sage dann weiterhin noch das Falsche. Genauso wie ich Denzel Washington sage und nicht Denzel Washington, obwohl es richtig wäre. Ich sage trotzdem noch das Falsche. Oder man sagt einfach zum Beispiel wegen dem Problem und nicht wegen des Problems. Nein, das sage ich nicht, weil es einfach
unsympathisch klingt und irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit
auf einen zieht, die man nicht will. Man will einfach
seine fucking Fleischbällchen haben und die
in sich reinstopfen, weil man innerlich leer ist
und irgendwas braucht, um seine Hülle zu füllen.
Schatbeler!
Und dann kannst du es ja beliebig übertreiben.
Und deswegen
ist es schwierig, aber ich habe Köttbüller gesagt und kam gut an. So geht es mir bei manchen Namen, ausländischen Namen auch, wo ich denke, nee, ich sage das jetzt nicht so, weil ich werde es eh verhunzen und dann fühle ich mich fast schlechter. Also ich weiß auch, dass es Utrecht, Utrecht heißt. Aber gerade bei Stadtnamen, ich meine meine, man sagt doch auch London, so niemand, wenn du London sagen würdest, das ist doch Quatsch. Es gibt ja auch einfach Munich für München, du erwartest doch nicht von dem Engländer, dass er München sagt, sondern es heißt Munich. So gibt es halt ausländische Aussprachen von Städtenamen. Notre-Dame. Notre-Dame, Barcelona. So, das ist ... Barcelona. Wie ist das auch Quatsch? Von daher habe ich da überhaupt keinen ... Milano. Ja, dann bin ich mit meinem Kumpel nach Milano gefahren und dann Roma. Ja, ist ja Quatsch. Du sagst ja auch Parmesan. Parmigiano. So, das ist ja völlig in Ordnung. Ja, aber das stimmt.
In gewisser Weise ist Wissen wahnsinnig unsexy.
Ja, es ist super schlimm.
Also nicht Schöpular sagen, sondern einfach, ich hätte gerne die Frickadösen.
Ich hätte gerne die Fleischpflanze.
Gute Frage, finde ich eine sehr, sehr gute Frage. Auch die ganzen Produktnamen natürlich, immer so schön deutsch aussprechen, als hätte man sie noch nie vorher gesehen. Ja. So mit dem Zeigefinger nachlesen, nicht so, als hätte man sich online eh schon informiert, was man genau braucht. Auf der internationalen Aussprachdatenbank, wo du alles genau perfekt sagst, sondern einfach so richtig sagen.
Finde ich, ist sympathischer, muss man machen.
Ikea bringt nächstes Jahr im Februar,
und da möchte ich, dass ihr euch anschnallt,
richtig tolle Sachen raus.
Die bringen, die haben gerade eh so einen
richtig geilen Run, so einen richtig geilen
Lauf, die sind richtig cool drauf.
Die bringen nämlich so alte
70er-Jahre-Möbel, die sie damals hatten
und damals war Ikea sausauschick. Br bringen die jetzt peu à peu raus von einem Designer. Und die sind wirklich absolut amazing. Ich habe schon einen Sessel von denen, Divlinge, Divling. Und der ist super. Und der kommt jetzt bald in Orange noch raus. Und dann kommt so ein geiles Regalsystem von dem gleichen Designer. Das ist alles fantastisch. Da kommt noch ein richtig geiles Sofa. Ab Februar 2025 die Augen offen halten, läuft nicht zu Ikea, rennt. War das die Werbung? Tatsächlich die Daim-Torte ist auch gut, aber leider Ikea aus dem Sortiment genommen die Schokoküsse. Die hatten früher die Schokoküsüsse ohne Waffel unten, skeptisch, skeptisch, skeptisch, sehr gute Schokoküsse, allerdings ohne Waffel unten dran. Habe ich trotzdem immer gerne mitgenommen, gibt es nicht mehr. Was es dafür gibt, auch inzwischen im Rewe, bin ich sehr froh darüber, Giflar, diese geilen Zimtschleppchen. Ah ja, Giflar, ja, Giflar. Giflar. Man ist an einem ganz komischen Ort in Skandinavien. Giflar! Das ist irgendwie so zwischen Schlaganfall und Wutausbruch irgendwie so. Immer wenn man Schwedisch redet, dann löst sich was in dir selber. Das ist immer ganz merkwürdig. Man muss so aussprechen, dass mein Schlüssel dazu, dass danach noch was kommt. Das ist wie geschnitten. Sie sprechen wie geschnitten.
Ich war letztens in einem anderen Möbelladen, der nicht Ikea ist,
aber fast Ikea ist, man kann sich ja nicht
dagegen wehren, dass jeder Möbelladen mit
Ikea verglichen wird. Und da
finde ich es immer ganz spannend zu schauen, für mich der
Charakter eines Möbelladens, er misst sich
immer danach, was die als Beispiel Bücher
haben, weil du hast ja Regale mit Büchern drin. Und ich glaube, bei Ikea gibt es ja irgendwie dann auch so Fantasiebücher oder so Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr so ihr Markending mit Schweden und da, das war aber ein deutsches, original deutsches Möbelhaus und da war natürlich die Frage, was steht da und da stand tatsächlich Hermann Hesse. Star Wars Episode 2. Als Buch? Als Buch.
Hä?
Als geschriebener Fliestext, Romantext, Star Wars Episode 2. Und du konntest wirklich reinlesen, wirklich mit Klonkriegern Kamino, genau da, wo wir schon waren, wo wir aufgelegt, aufgehört haben. Aufgelegt. Genau. Und wo ich mir dachte, wow, also Wahnsinn. Vor allem, warum Episode 2? Es war zwei, also ich habe geguckt, es war immer Episode zwei, also es war wirklich so eine Regalreihe komplett durch, immer Episode zwei und es war jedes auch echtes Buch, jedes war echtes Buch. Aber bei Ikea sind das keine echten Bücher, meine ich. Bei Ikea sind es glaube ich nur die Deckblätter Cover, aber so von schwedischen Büchern und da war Starffekt zwei jedes Mal, aber es waren komplette lesbare Bücher. Wahnsinn. So viele Fragen. Ja. Vor allem Star Wars verstehe ich ja, ist ja irgendwie Mainstream. Aber Bücher in Buchform ja gar nicht. In Buchform, und vor allem warum nicht die alte Trilogie? Ja, ja. Also die beliebte Trilogie. Warum denn Star Wars, die meisten selbst Star Wars Fans werden sagen, der Zweite ist der Schlechteste, der will jetzt gar keine riesen Diskussion anfangen, aber niemand sagt, der zweite ist ein hervorstehender, guter Star-Wars-Film. Jetzt muss ich aber auch sagen, ketzerisch, diese Möbelhäuser, über die du gerade sprichst, sind jetzt auch nicht für ihr Stil bekannt. Richtig, aber trotzdem, irgendjemand muss ja die Entscheidung getroffen haben. Und dann nimm doch Hermann Hesse, nimm doch Siddhartha oder was auch immer. Aber nimm doch nicht Star-Wars-Episode 2, Angriff der Klonkrieger. Jede Oma, die das Ding in der Hand hat, nennt sich Angriff der Klonkrieger. Wo bin ich, was ist denn jetzt los? Also es klingt ja so merkwürdig und weltfremd und damit kann ich auch nichts anfangen. Erst wollen die da sich Gender, dann die Wärmepumpe und jetzt auch noch Klonkrieger? Das ist nicht mehr mein Deutschland.
Das ist nicht mehr mein XXL-Lutz.
XXLutz.
Aber ganz merkwürdig, ich habe reingelesen.
Gutes Buch.
Der Film ist das Florentin.
Das ist nicht das Skript.
Fließtext einfach.
Ich habe ja damals, habe ich ja Star Wars Episode 3,
habe ich gelesen, bevor ich es gesehen habe. Und zwar kam der Film ja raus, als ich im Italien Urlaub war, Rache der Sith, und dann wusste ich, oh, der Film wird rauskommen, wenn ich in Italien bin. Soll ich in italienisches Kino gehen? No. Ich werde mir ein Buch kaufen, die gab es schon vor Filmrelease, und hab das mitgenommen und hab im Urlaub das Buch gelesen, was eine sehr gute Entscheidung war, weil ich dadurch selber gelesen habe und cool und dauert ewig, kannst du über die ganze Woche im Urlaub lesen und danach habe ich mir erst den Film angeschaut, war richtig cool und genauso war das auch Star Wars Episode 2.
Weil in der Film so, wie du dir das vorgestellt hast.
Ja.
Weil auch Bilder drin waren. In der Mitte, das gibt es manchmal,
dass in der Mitte des Buchs Bilder sind,
die aber alles beschreiben,
nicht nur das, was in der Mitte passiert.
Das finde ich immer so verwirrend irgendwie. In der Mitte, das gibt es manchmal, dass in der Mitte des Buchs Bilder sind, die aber alles beschreiben, nicht nur das, was in der Mitte passiert.
Das finde ich immer so verwirrend irgendwie. Und dann, wahrscheinlich hat das so buchdrucktechnische Gründe, dass du die dann auf einem anderen Papier, sind die gedruckt und du kannst es nicht überall einstreuen, wäre wahrscheinlich teurer, würde den Preis heben, acht Prozent, neun Prozent, vielleicht zehn Prozent. Und deswegen macht man es alles in der Mitte, ist es einfacher.
Und da konnte ich es dann schon der Mitte, ist es einfacher.
Und da konnte ich es dann schon lesen und du liest das halbe Buch und dann hast du noch mal Bilder vom Anfang.
Dann denkst du, wo bin ich jetzt?
Hä, ist ein Zeitsprung?
Hey, weil auf Camino waren wir doch vor neun Tagen.
Und dann liest du da, da bin ich.
Und dann liest du, schaust du die Bilder auch noch an,
die dann in der zweiten Hälfte kommen werden oder nicht?
Oh, du bist kurz weggespoilert.
Du bist vollkommen verwirrt, du musst ganz schwer entscheiden. Mich sind die das nicht mögen. Und dann musst du ganz schwere Entscheidungen treffen, die du eigentlich nicht treffen willst, wenn du ein Buch liest. Ein Buch nimmt dir jede Entscheidung ab. Erst Seite 1, dann Seite 2, dann Seite 3. Ich muss nichts entscheiden. Außer mein geiles Gänsehaut-Buch, wo man choose your own story. Wenn du den Gang lang gehen willst, dann blätter auf Seite 89. Und dann blätter man nach 89. Da ist nicht 1, 2, 3. Da ist 1, 2, 89, 54, 63, 112. Und am Ende stirbst du bei jedem Turn. Hast du nach deinem Tod noch mal alle anderen durchprobiert? Ich glaube schon, ja. Das habe ich sehr gut gefunden, dieses Buch. Aber ist das wirklich gruselig? Die Gänsehautbücher für Kinder, ja. Ich finde, wenn du selber Entscheidungen treffen kannst, wird es weniger gruselig. Kontrovers, auch Videospiele und so, finde ich nicht gut. Kontrovers auch fürs echte Leben. Fürs echte Leben. Weil da, würde ich sagen, zeichnet die Angst ja vor allen Dingen aus, dadurch aus, dass du selber eine Entscheidung treffen kannst. Nee, ich finde, Geisterbahn zum Beispiel, du kannst nicht kontrollieren und deswegen ist es schrecklich. Die furchtgrusigsten Geisterbahnen sind die, wo du durchlaufen kannst. Habe ich noch nie erlebt, deswegen kann ich es nicht beurteilen. Ich war generell nur ein einziges Mal in meinem Leben der Geisterbahn. Ich stelle dir eine andere Frage. Ich war auf der ... Florentin, findest du ... Stopp, stopp, stopp. Welche Geisterbahn fändest du, wenn du jetzt davor zwei stündest, gruseliger? Die, durch die du fährst oder die, durch die du läufst? Wie gesagt, da ich ... Nee. ... gleiche Antwort. Wie gesagt. Nein, du antwortest auf eine falsche Frage. Weil ich noch nie durch eine gelaufen bin, kenne ich diese Experience nicht. Und würde allein aus Neugiergründen, würde ich es anwählen. Ich war ein einziges Mal in meinem Leben in der Geisterbahn auf der Wiesn mit meinem Vater, bin ich in der Geisterbahn, wollte unbedingt in die Geisterbahn, dann fährt der Wagen los, ich kneife die Augen zu, halte mir die Ohren zu und fahre den kompletten Weg durch die Geisterbahn und dann raus. mein Vater dachte sich, okay, da waren wir jetzt 20 Minuten angestanden. Naja, so ist das nun mal.
Angestanden.
Zu viel angestanden. Naja, so ist das nun mal. Angestanden. Zu viel angestanden. Du hast lustigerweise ... Da haben wir jetzt angestanden. Da kam zum ersten Mal in 400-plus-Folgen dein Dialekt durch. Da kam der echte Will Florentin durch, der jetzt tatsächlich durch die Wut gelöst wurde. So, Will Florentin nächstes Jahr auf die Wiesen? Ja, oder? Podcast-Ufo-X-Wiesen auf jeden Fall, oder? Schön aus dem Riesenrad. Machen wir mal. Ja, das wird doch richtig grossartig. Mit dem Käfer-Zelt, mit dem Zeltkäfer. Richtig schön. Die sagen ja immer, alles verdreht. Das ist immer, ja, da muss man aufpassen. Das ist super schwer. Aber das machen wir schön mit so Liebkuchenherzen und sowas. Ja, ich werde so richtig reingehen und dann wie ich Schöttbular sage, würde ich dann auch da im Bayerischen unterwegs sein. In Essen war ich tatsächlich kurz auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt. Das war für mich eine wirkliche Weihnachtserfahrung. Ich lind den Weihnachtsmarkt. Ich trinke da Glühwein, ich trinke noch einen Glühwein, ich trinke noch einen Glühwein.
Aber Weihnachtsmarkt, ich gehe hin und verlasse es super gestresst, weil ich scoute immer, ah okay, es gibt hier Backschinken, es gibt hier Raclette, es gibt hier Würstchen, es gibt hier Ribs, Langosch, es gibt Feuerlachs, Flammlachs, hin und her, ich gucke mir alles an. Lava Lachs, und da dachte ich mir, kann ich mehrere essen und so.
Was ich richtig cool fand, war der Ber mir, kann ich mehrere essen und so.
Was ich richtig cool fand, war den Bericht, den ich mit laufendem Mund gelesen habe, von einem, ich glaube in Berlin war es, Weihnachtsmarkt, wo es ein Euken-Eat-Angebot gab.
Wo du einmal zahlst und dann hast du überall an jedem Stand Essen.
Und ich dachte mir, meine Herren, wie gut, dass ich nicht mehr in Berlin lebe, weil ich hätte einfach wirklich mich einfach zur Explosion gebracht. Ist das ein externer Anbieter oder ist das ein Anbieter, der hat ein Buffet? Nee, ich glaube, die haben sich schon geeinigt, die Buden darauf, dass die das gemeinsam machen. Ist es eine externe Bude, die sich da hinstellt und sagt, wenn sie bei uns folgendes Ticket kaufen und dann haben die so geheime Abmachungen mit den anderen Buden. Wie lief das logistisch ab? Ob du das jetzt bei der Extra-Bude kaufst oder bei den jeweiligen Essensbuden, die diesen Chip kaufst. Du hast den Artikel gelesen. Ich habe den Artikel, ja, ich habe die ersten drei Wörter der Überschrift gelesen. Du hast den Tweet gelesen über den Artikel. Ich habe das Bild gesehen, dann lief so viel Sabber auf meiner Tastatur, dass ich erst mal da Notwasser musste, ab, abwischen musste und dann war auch der Artikel wieder geschlossen und dann war ich wieder zurück auf meinen anderen Seiten. Wenn du verstehst, was ich meine. Ja, jeder versteht, was war für mich eine ... Tortur?
Eine Höllenritt.
Nee, es ist wenig, wenig passiert, was man so in den Händen halten kann.
Okay.
Aber ich fand es wunderschön.
Ich fand es auch sehr, sehr schön.
Du hast ja deine Schreibreise gemacht, du hast herrlich was geschrieben,
RAF nochmal neu beleuchtet von unten. Der Film, da kann man was in den Händen halten, das finde ich sehr gut. Sonst generell ist gerade da eine schwierige Branche. Werden wir den sehen, 2025, den RAF von unten Film? Nein? Das ist auch wirklich spannend, kurz mal um ernste Töne anzuschlagen, bin ich da jetzt zum ersten Mal so richtig unmittelbar von
politischem Schwachsinn betroffen.
Denn das Filmfördergesetz
gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Und jetzt werden keine Filme mehr
gefördert und so, und wahrscheinlich
je nachdem, was gewählt
wird, dann
wird auch nicht mehr viel. Jetzt setzt du den Hörern aber die Pistole
auf die Brust. Jetzt wird dann noch nicht mehr so viel
für Filme und Kultur ausgegeben, und das ist sehr, sehr schlimm. Und da bin ich zum ersten Mal, seitdem ich denken kann, so richtig unmittelbar betroffen. Also klar, man ist immer betroffen. Ja, ja. Aber so richtig unmittelbar kriegt man einen Platz. So dass du zu den wenigen Leuten gehörst, spezielles Thema, ja. Mit einem sehr speziellen Thema, genau. Und das nervt mich sehr. Dann mein Tipp einfach für den Wahlkampf, ich finde, die jeweiligen Parteien sollten dann auch wirklich damit werben, haben gesagt, Leute, wenn ihr den RAF Roboterfilm von Stefan Tietze sehen wollt, wählt mich für Roboter. Roboter Army Friends. Ja, Robot Army Friends. Dann wählt uns. Rest mal egal gerade. Wir haben ja gelernt, es ist wichtig, auf kleine Themen runterzudampfen. Deswegen, liebe Parteien, hier mein Tipp. Für 25, fokussiert euch auf diesen RAF-Film. Ja, Roboter Army Friends. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch natürlich, jetzt sind wir leider nicht zu unserem Jahresrück weggekommen, Mensch, ich hatte extra alles vorbereitet, ich hatte jeden Monat hier hatte ich vorbereitet, aufgerisselt, alles, konnten wir leider nicht mehr dazugekommen, weil Stefan diese zu viel zu erzählen hat. Naja, das war die Folge, macht's gut, wir sind nächste Woche auch wieder mit dabei, wir wünschen euch natürlich einen ganz, ganz guten Rutsch ins neue Jahr, ganz viel Spaß, schön Jahresende, schön Jahresanfang, macht was ihr wollt, lasst es euch gut gehen und wir sehen uns natürlich ... Willst du doch nochmal irgendwann deine Fresse halten? Wir sehen uns natürlich im nächsten Jahr, auch wieder, macht's gut, tschüss, bis nächste Mal! Schönes, schönes Jahr, vielen Dank für alles, tschau, tschau, ihr macht's gut, tschau, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, rui, r Fros Neusjahr.
Ja, haben wir doch gerade schon gesagt.
It's a Worst Bird Production.
Fros Neusjahr. Standard? Willkommen im Ruhrgebiet. Echt statt inszeniert. Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt.
Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde.
Klingt anders? Ist es auch. Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet.